حصلت الجزيره ايضا على صور لقصف اسرائيلي
على شكل حزام ناري على مخيمي البريج
والمغازي في المحافظه الوسطى بقطاع
غزا مقاتلات الاحتلال الحربيه تنفذ غارات
عنيفه في المحافظه الوسطى حزامات ناريه
وانفجارات قويه في هذه اللحظات تنفذ في
مخيم
البريج لا تزال الانفجارات القويه في
المحافظه الوسطى كما
نشاهد تابع واياكم هذا القصف العنيف في
هذه اللحظات قصف
عنيف قصف عنيف في المحافظه الوسطى
مخيط
البريج مخيم البريج الان يتعرض ل عدوان
كبير وقصف همجي من المقاتلات الحربيه كما
نشاهد واياكم هذه
الح مارات عني
نحن بالقرب من هذه الاماكن التي يتم
استهداف ومن هذه المقاتلات الحربيه والحزم
الناريه القويه جدا التي تنفذها مقاتلات
الاحتلال الحربيه باتجاه اهداف في
المحافظه الوسطى تحديدا مخيم البريج مخيم
المغازي شارع صلاح الدين عشرات الغارات
الان تنفذ بشكل عنيف في المحافظه
الوسطه الطيرات الحربيه
تقصف مخيم البريج مخيم المغازي اطراف مخيم
النصيرات شارع صلاح الدين المنطقه
الشماليه للمحافظه الوسطى منطقه الدعوه
منطقه وادي غزه جل هذه المناطق في
المحافظه الوسطه لن تشهد استهدافات عنيفه
من قبل المقاتلات الحربيه نستمع الى قذيفه
الان جديده
قصف عف من مدفعيه الاحتلال
في على شارع صلاح الدين بالمحافظه الوسطى
لربما سقط هذه
القذيفه بالقرب من المكان الذي اتواجد به
يصعب دخول طواقم الانقاذ كذلك ك طواقم
الاسعاف يصعب عليهم الدخول لهذه المنطقه
المستهدفه التي استهدفتها مقاتلات
الاحتلال الحربيه بعشرات
الغارات